tirs de mortiers jets de cocktails
molotov
une épaisse fumée se propage près du
lycée hélène-boucher près dans ces
conditions là qu'il nous faut apporter
des réponses en termes d'abord
d'interpellation et de sanctions
extrêmement ferme que je souhaite
vraiment exemplaire des auteurs de ces
agressions parce que c'est insupportable
la proviseure tentera de ramener le
calme elle sera blessé au visage par
plusieurs jeunes et transporté à
l'hôpital par manuel valls eux prévient
l'état poursuivra sans relâche ceux qui
s'en prennent à nos professeurs nos
écoles et aussi nos forces de l'ordre
fin de citation vous dites carrément que
sarkozy hollande ont du sang sur les
mains c'est une accusation très fort pas
que sont là que tous ceux qui ont tous
ceux qui ont organisé cette enfin
organise cette style cette situation
dans laquelle nous sommes devenus des
alliés des semences et du djihad vous
m'envoyez de soissons il va régler le
problème
vous voyez où tim wallach vous voyez
comme c'est pas du tout monsieur bourdin
timide habitude sympa mais là vous êtes
ignobles
c'est à dire il y aura des territoires
qui seront concédées à des stades où il
y aura des tribunaux islamiques comment
certaines régions angleterre où on
pourra pas ratifier légalement la charia
ça s'appelle une méthode très
particulière du journal c'est la
question accusations est ce que c'est
vrai que vos assistance met à poil
vous voulez de refuser de vous asseoir
vous sur le canapé de karine marchand
sur m6 alors que la plupart sont allés
dire papa maman ma première masturbation
c'était l'âge était ce qu'elle vous a
proposé à vos marx dans quelques mois là
c'est quand même c'est vrai mais bien
sûr mais vous savez je suis aussi comme
vous l'actualité je vois que parfois la
forme propositions ça donne des
cacophonies incompréhensible voilà ce
que dit la hollande mélenchon il fait
partie des soldats perdus il se sent
humiliée je le connais depuis si
longtemps
je les ai vus ramper pour entrer au
gouvernement jospin
c'est bien lui il venimeux comme comme
pas un vrai drame
aujourd'hui c'est ça il n'a prime plus
vis-à-vis des français il est déconnecté
des français à recoller gaulle à sarkozy
mentor et skate et en short l'escalier
sacré de l'entrée de l'elysée il
discrédite totalement la fonction
présidentielle et jacques chirac n'a pas
manqué aussi de ce genre de debès fait
vous voyez alain juppé vous dites quoi
la population qui vieillit j'ai de plus
en plus vieux oui oui c'est pas faux
mais mais mais revenons à vos
engagements politiques
est ce que vous sentez un peu
aujourd'hui comme un missionnaire c'est
une position que j'ai bien connu je me
souviens du premier ministre de l'époque
disant je suis à la tête d'un etat en
faillite et qui cinq ans plus tard
laisse 600 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire à la france
parlons un peu de votre femme j'imagine
que votre relation susciter quelques
jalousies
je rappelle que c'est pas une place que
j volets ont été reçus attribué qui est
une compétition
j'ai été élu au premier tour avec 65%